se trata de un proceso histórico en
contra de 14 personas acusadas de haber
participado material o intelectualmente
en la serie de ataques yihadistas que
tuvo lugar en enero del año 2015 en
parís en contra de la revista satírica
saliendo pero también en contra de un
supermercado judío de la post de bánzer
y en contra de una policía en el sur de
parís de esas personas tres están
ausentes una de ellas es una mujer
hallazgo media en considerada la esposa
religiosa de amedik oliva lee el autor
de la toma de rehenes y del ataque en
contra del supermercado judío y de la
muerte de la policía en la comuna de
movus al sur de parís
ella se encuentra fuera de los radares
de la policía se presume que está en
zona sirio iraquí y una hija dista
francesa que volvió hace poco a
territorio galo dice haberla visto con
vida a los otros son los hermanos
belushi mohamed el mayor está acusado de
ser el mentor de amélie olivelli y de
ser un apoyo clave en el atentado que él
realizó contra el supermercado
y su hermano menor mehdi es quien sacó
de territorio francés una semana antes
de los atentados ha hallado medio en
dirección a turquía pasando por madrid
el resto de los acusados pertenecen en
su mayoría al entorno de ahmed y juli
valley pero hay uno que es muy
importante ali resa bolat 1 franco turco
que habría sido el único vínculo entre
los hermanos quay y autores de la
matanza contra charlie hebdo y ahmed y
cully valley